europe is in the middle of an intense
third wave in the coronavirus pandemic
in france more than 100 000 people have
now died from covet 19.
meanwhile germany is seeing its largest
rise in new infections
since early january that is despite
vaccinations picking up pace
new national controls have been approved
by the country's cabinet but
they could take another week to pass
through parliament doctors and health
officials are pleading for immediate
action
on germany's intensive care wards this
is what the third wave looks like
more than 29 000 new covert 19 cases
were reported on thursday
the highest number since early january
doctors are warning that in parts of the
country only 10 percent of intensive
care beds are unfilled
the head of germany's public health
institute is alarmed
christ it is clear that we need to act
now on all levels above all the decision
makers need to take action
we need to reduce our contacts now break
the infection chain now and save lives
in the health of many people
but not all decision makers share that
sense of urgency
in particular some regional leaders have
been reluctant to implement tough
restrictions
now chancellor merkel is introducing a
change in the law
to grant the central government
temporary powers to enforce lockdowns in
areas with high infections
but even for the health minister this
could be too
little too late
i already said a week ago that we needed
extra measures and that we needed to
take
firm action time is not on our side and
everyone already has the option to be
taking measures
they need not wait for the law to be
finalized
the new nationwide regime mandates
school closures and contact restrictions
when infection rates hit
defined levels much of the public
supports tough action
but critics say the focus is too much on
limiting
personal freedoms for instance with the
proposed introduction of nighttime
curfews
a lot of people of my age will just meet
at home in secret curfews won't get this
under control people will meet privately
but i think we just need to shut things
down for four weeks
those who didn't follow the rules before
won't listen to these new laws but those
who did obey feel they're being treated
like fools
restrictions in some parts of germany
have been light for much of the pandemic
but as laws are tightened people here
are having to face the fact
that coronavirus not only costs lives
it corrodes liberty as well
well a debate over whether to grant the
central government more powers for
pandemic management is currently playing
out in the german bundestag
earlier chancellor angela merkel made
her case to members of parliament
if we've learned the lesson 13 months
into the pandemic
it's this the virus
doesn't forgive any half-heartedness it
only makes things worse
the virus doesn't forgive hesitation it
just makes
everything last longer the virus doesn't
accept any negotiations
it understands only one language the
language of determination
our chief political correspondent
melinda crane is following the debate at
the bundestag for us hi melinda
we saw chancellor merkel making her case
there earlier
are we going to see german lawmakers
today finally take those steps that
public
health officials and doctors really are
pleading for
the chancellor gave quite a vehement
defense of this draft law and the
government had originally hoped for
action this week
but it's not going to happen here today
in fact policymakers are now
saying it will take at least another
week until the law
passes both chambers of parliament and
even then
some provisions including for example
the curfew could wind up being
challenged
in court uh by members of the
opposition so it will take a while it's
not going to get here quickly enough to
stop this third wave in its tracks
we're more than one year into this
pandemic melinda why is there still no
clear consensus among germany's leaders
on
how to tackle it
well as we heard in the report one
reason is german federalism until now
the country's
infectious disease laws have put most of
the responsibility for pandemic
management in the hands of the federal
states and because infection rates and
conditions
vary from region to region there has
been quite a discrepancy in the way that
different federal states have
interpreted
the rules and then there's very
justified concern
on the part of the policy makers and
we've heard this in the debates here
today
about incursions on basic freedoms that
are guaranteed
in germany's uh constitution in
particularly
when it comes to rather drastic measures
like a curfew so we heard the chancellor
in her remarks talking about the need
for proportionality between burdens
and benefits but crafting a law
crafting a curfew restrictions in order
to ensure that kind of proportionality
can become a matter that drifts into
microregulation
and hair splitting and we're also
hearing some of that here today
interestingly enough among the broader
population there is
pretty strong consensus on the need for
tighter
measures and even on the curfew and
maybe we can take a quick look at the
statistics
they are even there we see a slim
majority of germans
and nearly all supporters of the
governing parties and the mainstream
opposition parties
supporting uh a curfew with 46 percent
uh nonetheless skeptical melinda just
quickly
we have seen a glimmer of hope this week
with back to nations picking up pace
will that be enough to break this third
wave
not for quite some time we're now just
short of 18 percent of the population
having been vaccinated for a first time
but as you know
herd immunity requires that a large
majority of the population
have been vaccinated and become immune
and we're still a long way away from
that
our chief political correspondent
melinda crane reporting from the
bundestag for us
thank you very much
you